the London Zoo is pushing back against
critics who don't like it's late night
parties for adults
only I know what you're thinking it's
not that kind of party there advertises
an event where people can enjoy seeing
the animals after hours see activists
say that noisy visitors and too much
alcohol put some of the zoo's 19
thousand animals at risk empty as tyub
went to see the nightlife for himself
and the wildlife it's one of the world's
oldest zoos home to lions tigers and
beers if you're thinking oh my then
you're not alone this summer the London
Zoo is hosting what it's calling zoo
nights where grown-ups can get closer to
wildlife with the glass of wine or three
it really feels like we're like almost
they got a music festival or something I
tell me about the box yeah it does
especially with all the food stands and
face paints zoo nights is making a
comeback after being cancelled in 2015
following reports of wasted visitors
harassing animals and enclosures I think
this whole idea that it's um lots of
people coming in and getting drunk and
doing things that they shouldn't be
doing is really exaggerated Brian
Zimmerman is the chief curator of the
London Zoo there's been a few isolated
incidents from several years ago they
were dealt with at the time and we
haven't had anything for the last few
years
areas have been closed off to protect
the more sensitive animals and extra
staff are on hand in case anyone gets
out of control it's not all fun and
fauna for visitors
with protesters grading them as they
arrived
critics say the zoo is putting profits
over animal protection Geordie Casa
manana works with PETA there is
scientific evidence that show the loud
noises affect animals in captivity a lot
they get fearful they got a stressful
zoo nights is expected to make over a
million dollars this summer with most of
the cash going to conservation projects
but more than a hundred and fifty
thousand people have already signed a
petition demanding the event be shut
down saying party animals shouldn't be
anywhere near wild ones in captivity for
CBS this morning
MPs Thai of London pretty move on say
but I think you have to take it into
consideration if it is hurting the
animals we like to see that it's a
legitimate concern that all these people
suddenly are swarming and it makes sense
to me you're supposed to in the habitat
you're mimicking the wild it's a wild
you don't have a lot of people knocking
back pines you know right actually one
tree away we hope not hope not